[Music]
begins other see what other nests does
is it Reis Accra Liza's our experience
of the world it very quickly dissipates
and strips away the sense of banality
that suffuses are typical waking
consciousness when we travel the
ordinary takes on a heightened
engagement there can be pleasure in the
nuance right having a conversation with
a waitress in a simple cafe in a country
you've never been can take on the
qualities of being in a museum Hall for
it is this heightened interestingness
that we are after there is this notion
of creating a new relationship a new
distance between you and that which is
familiar and then a new relationship
that closes that distance for it is
encountering the unknown that makes us
come alive but it is then our impulse to
marshal a response to contend and make
sense of the land beyond the maps that
is also part of the human story
why do I say this to you well I say this
to you because we all want to experience
heightened aliveness in the words of the
religious scholar Houston Smith we all
want to turn our passing illuminations
into abiding light which was echoed also
by Jamie wheal when he said we want to
take our altered states and divinations
and turn them into altered traits and
this requires a kind of remembering or
tapping into source code an awakening to
our common ecstasy it's like that great
line that says be humble for you're made
of Earth but be noble for you are made
of scars or that wonderful line by
Nikita Gill when she says we have
calcium in our bones and iron in our
veins carbon in our souls and nitrogen
in our brains ninety-three percent
Stardust with souls made of flames we
are all just stars that have people
names I mean my god at the end of the
day this is the unvarnished truth right
that great line that says the bad news
is we're all falling through space no
one knows what's going on and there's
nothing to hold on to but the good news
is there is no ground man there is no
ground I went to God just to see and I
was looking at me
it's terence mckenna's notion that the
answer lies in being awake do not give
in to the astonishment but pay attention
for absolute unmixed attention is a form
of Prayer said Simon a while and
attention if sudden enclosed graduates
into surprise and this into astonishment
and this into stupefied amazement said
Charles Darwin where Henry Miller who
said even an ordinary blade of grass
would given our complete unvarnished
attention becomes a miraculous
incomprehensible glistening object of
beauty an infinite thing in itself wake
the up cleanse your doors of
perception for Aldous Huxley said if the
doors of perception were cleansed
everything would appear to man as it is
infinite for is not this what we
ultimately want to strip away the
trappings of routine to strip away the
trappings of the familiar to awaken
ourselves to our common ecstasy to
salivate and froth at the mouth in the
face of infinity
we don't travel to move around said Pico
Iyer we travel in order to be moved I
don't cry when I'm sad said Dawkins I
cry when I moved we don't cry when
something as sad said Alan they're both
on we cry when something is more
beautiful than we expected it to be true
healing lies in piercing our
representations and getting to the
territory beyond the maps in the
violating or expectations right in
having encounters of knowledge by
acquaintance not just knowledge by
description you have to go there to know
me so go go
go
go you will find what you are looking
for you will behold the Wishing Well you
will have the cosmic download and you
were bathed in existential delights and
I want nothing less for you and nothing
less for me for this is our common
ecstasy
[Music]
behold behold behold behold
old
[Music]